joining me now is martin luther king the
third global human rights activist and
of course the son
of martin luther king very good to talk
to you thank you very much indeed for
joining us and
let's talk about that service first of
all what did you make of it quite a
tribute to john lewis
it certainly was in our tradition we
call it an extraordinary home going
where many paid phenomenal tributes
uh certainly three presidents former
presidents
uh as as as well as those who were very
close to
uh the congressman but an extraordinary
homegoing service
we're going to sorely miss his
leadership his moral leadership because
he was not just the conscience
of the congress but perhaps he was even
the conscious of had grown to become the
conscious
of our nation and tell us of course
about his
his work with your father we can see the
the portrait
behind you there just tell us what you
what you witnessed in terms of the
dynamic between them
well first of all as a child uh the
congressman was in and out of our home
so i remember him and because he worked
with my father
uh in many ways as the student
non-violent coordinating committee
uh chairperson and and leader for a
period of time
i knew him then and because he worked
with dr abernathy and
jose williams and andrew young and a
host of others
all of these gentlemen uh harry
belafonte
also uh worked very closely with my dad
became
i like our play uncles so john lewis was
like our play uncle
but as i grew older and ultimately
once he was elected to office i happened
to be elected at the same time
and he served as a city councilman here
in atlanta i served as a fulton county
commissioner
and we worked together over the years of
course he worked with my mother
and continued to work with her once he
went to congress to help
get certain legislation passed over and
over again and my mom did her part to
get the help
lobby for the legislation but in terms
of my father and he
he first my father first met him i think
at 18 years old
dad uh and the organization paid for a
ticket for him to come from troy
uh to montgomery and he had
already been listening to my father's
speeches so he was inspired
by his speeches and his example dad was
of the personification of non-violence
john lewis ultimately personified
non-violence
uh and peacefulness throughout his life
so you really well placed then to give
us an insight
into his character you know we heard
there
some of those eulogies talking about
john lewis how humble he was but how
determined and persistent as well
yes he was he was unyielding
in a sense but he did it in a way that
you had to respect him
regardless of if you agreed with what he
was advocating for
now of course i would be on a side that
agreed with everything
uh that he was advocating there were
others in congress who may not have
agreed
but they respected him and came to
admire
and and love him because he did it in
such a way in the sense
my father taught us how to be
disagreeable without
how to be uh constructive without being
disagreeable so you didn't have to be
hostile
uh yes you were very passionate but you
didn't have to exhibit anger you did not
have to personally
attack someone because they had a
different position
than yours and this this is called
character
this is called integrity uh this is
called
also a vision john lewis shared her
vision
and he kept coming back over and over
and over again
used to say don't give up don't give out
and in a sense don't give in
and he personified all of that open
doors and unfortunately we're still
having challenges around
voting in this 2000 in 2020 we're going
to have
challenges that we have to address
because there is voter suppression
that has been uh voted on all throughout
many of our states and congressman lewis
wanted to make it possible for all of us
to vote we
we need to reenact what we call the
voting rights act
in fact the house of representatives
passed a bill the john
lewis restoration voter registration act
and it is my hope the senate will do
that uh they have not so far but yes it
has happened in
in the house yeah and we heard barack
obama getting very angry
about that but but what does it tell us
then about the current state of race
relations in
the united states that three former
presidents
from all parties attended but of course
the
the current one the serving one did not
so i i think it says that the current
president is operating
exclusively from a from a narrow
political perspective
believing i mean you know you have to
acknowledge the fact that he attacked
john lewis um he attacked the district
uh john lewis did not go to his
inauguration because he did not feel
that he had been elected in a
responsible way
and uh so there have been issues all
along but
the higher issue is that when you talk
about
race relations my father wanted to
eradicate what he called were the triple
evils and my mother in their lives
and those are the evils of poverty
racism and violence
and of course while we've made strides
unfortunately
the president current president has
intentionally attempted to divide people
and the hope is that
many many people will come together we
are seeing the largest civil rights
demonstrations
in the world with people holding signs
saying black lives matter
whether it's in europe or whether it's
in australia or whether it's in south
america
and obviously their demonstrations
consistently going on
here in the united states but these
demonstrations
are demonstrators are holding up signs
that say black lives matter
this we had a new juncture a new phase
john lewis
ambien who also passed on same day they
took their last march together
but what i think will happen or is
happening
is we're still working through race
we're not where we need to be
but we're going to get there because
there are far more people of goodwill
who believe in racial sensitivity than
those who are
segregationists and racists well martin
luther king the third it has been an
honor
and a pleasure talking to you and thank
you for those
insights into the life of a remarkable
man
very good talking to you thank you for
the opportunity